foi amigo de tudo bem não era um bom pai
tava bom mas assim mesmo só reviu na
festa esqueceu a pele plano perspectivo
tô acaba lhe que nesse vídeo vou doar
três centavos capiba
ah
e aí galera que aceite meu caminho
entendeu a piada do bicho saiu cá natal
muito humorista gente mais ou menos dois
anos atrás eu vim aqui nesse lugar a
adotar minha cachorrinha cabeça méxico
depois de um tempo que eu fiquei com ela
pegou a doença chamada calada é a
leishmaniose
você tem que sacrificar o animal oie doc
fazer o animal sobreviver só tomar o
remédio é uma meta imagine com uma
mulher na nova era pequenininha este mês
ela morreu eu fiquei pensando por que
você contava só ela estava comigo e aí
depois que parei de morar só porque ela
vai veio a morrer então eu tirei a base
na minha cabeça que ela cumpriu o que
ela tinha para fazer aqui na terra que
era me fazer companhia me ajuda e foi
aqui nesse lugar que eu adotei é o tempo
que o que eu adotei ela não podia nem
pegar mais animais nem podia ajudar os
que estão aqui que eu morava só eu
estava começando tudo não pode ver se
não tinha a segurança do que eu estava
fazendo ainda tinha acabado de sair de
casa não tinha dinheiro não tinha o que
fazer um lugar para morar e mesmo assim
o decidir pegar o animal para lhe fazer
companhia e eu posso falar pra vocês que
quando as melhores coisas que já fiz na
mídia foi a da américa para ficar comigo
e quase dobrou depois eu voltei aqui
agora esses animais e mostrar pra vocês
começou a idade o caso que sobrevive e
os animais sobrevive de doações de você
quer alguma coisa de que é só ajudo meus
olhos da nossa fundação a pipa amiga
total
e aqui neste lugar na fundação a pipa
sobre uma mais de 250 animais todos com
a ajuda de doações com a ajuda da
população pode ajudar a galera que não
tem nada de governo é é a uma pessoa que
criou se aqui falando senão a pessoa
falou não tem esse lugar tem esse
terreno é como fazer a pegar vários
animais a gente acha no meio da rua e
vamos tratar e aqui sobreviver mais de
250 animais só com a ajuda da população
só página de doação até porque sap pela
acho um animal no meio da rua foi
atropelado o animal está doente a pessoa
não quer mais criar então que jogar na
rua que eles fazem eles perdem em casa
pra cá tem total tratamento animal de
graça diversão fez de graça só com a
ajuda da população à população as vezes
que tem a galera que chega na porta da
afp um animal abandonado aqui na porta à
campainha vaga e ap tem outra opção a
não ser trazer o animal para tentar
arrumar um lugar que a gente já tem
engates mais mas como eu vim aqui tem
uma cena de cheiro de gás e eles às
vezes já tem gato de maio então que
resolvi fazer pra você e eu resolvi a
gente entrou em 2015 né esse vídeo é
sair do governo eu espero que um dia na
minha vida eu ia fazer isso também pegar
um terreno e pega um lugar construir um
lugar só pra dar tratamento animal aves
chegou porque sei lá eu eu sou uma
pessoa que gosta muito animal eu sou eu
sou pode ganhar o gosto de brincar
com o cachorro de família não tem agente
brasileiro fala por si mesma quando pega
o cachorro podem falar mandarim
libertações e vou tentar dormir aqui
fazendo a ajuda foi amigo de tudo bem
assim
na festa esqueceu a pele ano perspectiva
pronto
ao comentar em 2015 fazendo uma boa ação
powell isso não é comprometeu a pipa
hoje acaba lhe que nesse vídeo vou doar
três centavos cap por si mesmo você
talvez na casa life
nesse vídeo para lá que você der aqui
nesse vídeo corta três centavos para a
pista vai dar uma grana boa que vai dar
para comprar remédio vai dar para
comprar ração muito atendimento a há
muito o animal tem aqui e não vou me
comprometer com vocês e sei lá você faz
tanta coisa sedá-lo da lic tanta coisa
nessa internet e também espero que você
da lac internet vamos a eles eu li que é
de graça pra uma coisa boa que até o
final de janeiro fechou janeiro veja
quanto online tempo eu faço faça a conta
vem aqui entregue à fifa então acaba
like recebido três centavos para a pipa
ou de silagem para uma coisa boa nessa
vida é um like que muitas vezes e dá uma
besteira e agora fará uma coisa que vai
ajudar um monte de cachorro um monte de
gato um monte de animal e em 60 é
cavassin da equipa e roney da idéia e
deixa a mãe taxa de faca e foi então é
isso aí muito obrigado sempre assisti
esse vídeo até aqui o seu líquido dessa
vez vai ser muito muito muito mais
importante do que todos os vídeos
profissional é isso aí para lá e três
centavos e eu quero que você comente
aqui embaixo você tem um animal de
estimação como o nome dele o que você
gosta de fazer queijo noite passear
jogar eu gosto de jogar pra cima da
mortal
ai no chão abbas fashion anpac
muito obrigado chupetas e e clica em
inscrever se para você ver vídeos novos
a um vídeo bem engraçado em me segue
aqui no instagram vai ser bem supla em
altas fotos bem legais eu gosto do jeito
como está ele está chorando
parece esponja
ah
bom
hum
o